aquí definimos la variable aleatoria x
como el número de ejercicios que yo hago
en una semana esta tabla describe la
distribución de probabilidad de x como
pueden ver x solo puede tomar un número
finito de valores 0 1 2 3 o 4 debido a
que tenemos un número finito de valores
aquí le llamamos a esto una variable
aleatoria discreta pueden ver que esta
es una distribución de probabilidad
válida porque la suma de todas las
probabilidades es igual a 1.1 + punto
15.4 más 0.25 + punto 1 es igual a 1 y
ninguna de estas es una probabilidad
negativa lo que queremos ver en este
vídeo es la noción de un valor esperado
de una variable aleatoria discreta cuya
anotación es esta una forma de pensar en
esto es que una vez que calculamos el
valor esperado de esta variable
aleatoria para cierta semana tendremos
una idea del número esperado de
ejercicios a esto también se le conoce
como la media de una variable aleatoria
esta es la letra griega muy que a veces
usamos para denotar la media así que es
la media de la variable aleatoria x pero
como la calculamos para calcular la
tomamos la suma ponderada de los
diferentes resultados y los ponderamos
por sus probabilidades por ejemplo esto
va a ser el primer resultado 0 que es
ponderado por su probabilidad de 0.1 por
lo que es 0 por 0.1 más el siguiente
resultado 1 ponderado por su
probabilidad de 0.15 más el siguiente
resultado que es 2 por su probabilidad
más 2 por 0.4 más el resultado 3 por su
probabilidad de 0.25 y finalmente el
resultado 4 por su probabilidad 0.1
vamos a simplificarlo 0 por lo que sea
es 0 1 por punto 15.15 + 2 por punto 4
es punto 83 por punto 25 es punto 75 4
por punto uno es punto 4 sumamos los
números punto 15
punto 8 puntos 75 punto 45 50 y 10
llevamos 111 es 2008 es 10 + 7 17 4 es
21 todo esto va a ser igual a 2.1 una
forma de pensar en esto es que el valor
esperado de x el número esperado de
ejercicios que haré en una semana dada
esta distribución de probabilidad es 2.1
y ustedes me pueden decir un momento
todos los resultados aquí son números
enteros como puedo tener 2.1 ejercicios
en una semana
qué significa 2.1 de ejercicio esto no
quiere decir que esperen que en una
semana yo haga exactamente 2.1
ejercicios pero es valioso porque puedo
decir que en 10 semanas esperarían que
yo hiciera aproximadamente 21 ejercicios
quizá algunas semanas no haga ejercicio
y quizá en otras semanas haga dos o tres
o cuatro ejercicios pero en 100 semanas
pueden esperar que yo haya hecho 210
ejercicios así que aún para una variable
aleatoria que sólo puede tener valores
enteros podemos tener un valor esperado
que no sea entero y aún así siga siendo
útil